for me it's a lot of fun our fans are so
amazing anytime we get to show their new
stuff and get them excited that's one of
my favorite parts of doing this we had a
huge villain last season in savat our
what are they gonna be up against in
this new season we've had a speedster
villain for the last three years so we
we really wanted to do something
different so this year the flash and his
team will be up against the thinker
we're positing it as the world's fastest
man versus the world's fastest mind we
tend to think of the flash as an athlete
like a runner and so much of his
previous seasons have been about
training harder or I have to run faster
but he's up against a villain this
season that he can't outrun it's
somebody that he has to help think and
it's gonna take him and Cisco and
Caitlin and a few other surprise people
to be able to get one step ahead of the
thinker
I'm not Kaitlin anymore how are we gonna
meet Caitlyn where has she been I think
the best thing we can say is if you're a
fan of killer frost you won't be
disappointed and if you're a fan of
Caitlin snow
you won't be disappointed either thank
you guys anytime
[Music]
love the loss that vias suffer it's
important that we embrace the miracles -
I think hardship is what makes us
stronger where'd you come from various
you took an eleven-year-old boy with a
broken heart and he gave him a home
looking back I realized that that was
the night that we fell in love
I look at you battling the darkness with
honor and hope and I'm reminded there's
always another way always
whether you have stuck leaning in the
world whether or not you have your
powers you never give it's about one
note one idea but we can all stand up
for what's right no matter what
this is a war
right way as I of all the city house
they have no reason to be scared
Familia loves a superior you do this you
are someone else
this is Hawaiian if there's a cost I'll
pay
whatever Lisa meant to give
extraordinary abilities even more than a
pass to take on these streets
may the best vibe when you have failed
this city
just run as fast as you can I'll try to
keep up
if it does I will let you know
hey everybody its charlie we finally got
some new flash and they dropped a really
cool comic book trailer for all of the
shows there's also some other stuff too
that I'll play like they're gonna have
another earth from the multiverse called
Earth X that's been taken over by Nazis
and they'll have like a version of
Supergirl called over girl there and
it'll debut one of their other animated
characters but there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so they confirm a
couple big things I mostly listen to the
Caitlyn stuff because we already knew
about the thinker like it's just a
villain that Barry can't outrun but we
learned a couple more episode titles and
a couple of the characters were
confirmed for the first half of the
season so Andrew Kreisberg who I'm happy
hasn't completely left the show yet he's
been working mostly on Supergirl stuff
says that fans of killer frost
and Caitlyn will both be really jazzed
up I feel like most people want Caitlyn
to be killer frost so I don't know why
you'd be a fan of Caitlyn and not killer
frost maybe just people who don't like
comic book stuff but when he says that
it means that she'll probably just have
an easier time switching back and forth
between her personas like she'll be able
to use her powers as killer frost
without completely going off the deep
end mentally so they never did a great
job of explaining why Caitlyn went
cuckoo banana pants the minute her
powers were activated because Barry got
his speed force powers he didn't
automatically turn crazy if you want to
make the joke you could say he's been
crazy this whole time here's a really
good example of that so first time we
ever see Grant Gustin playing Barry
Allen is on arrow they debuted the
character there then he went off to the
pilot and they did the flash TV show
this is what he was like before he got
powers I'm sorry I'm late but actually
my train was late well the second one
the first one I did miss but that was my
cab drivers fault I've got this great
traffic app and he thought that he was
right I'm here now though so great who
the hell are you and do your parents
know that you're here I'm Barry Allen
from these Central City Police
Department and with the crime-scene
investigation unit so he gets hit with a
particle accelerator blast does not
automatically become evil so why then
does Caitlin automatically become evil
it just doesn't make sense I think it
was because they wanted her to be a
villain and they didn't have a good way
of explaining it so it seems like season
four Caitlin will be a more fun version
of the character that just has some dark
impulses they shall seize on every once
in a while and when she loses her [ __ ]
and starts using her powers that's when
her eyes will light up like this but the
rest of the time she'll look closer to
this and I think that's for practical
reasons as well as story reasons like
they want to have all the fun stuff but
they don't want all the baggage from
last season they don't want her to be a
huge bummer and they don't want danielle
panabaker to have to sit in a makeup
chair for eight hours before every
single day of filming Stephen Amell
actually said one time that the main
cast members on the shows typically
shoot more than 180 days a year
so that means like 180 days of 12 hour
days is crazy but the whole thing about
the flash versus The Thinker just
because it's going to be challenging
Barry's intellect his skills as a
detective which is probably why the
bringing the elongated man on because
he's also another detective with powers
from the comics is is that it's to be
doing a lot of Flash related stuff he'll
still be running around using his powers
the way you've seen in previous seasons
and because he's come out of the Speed
Force now he will have some new powers
as well I've already done a video about
that so it's in my season 4 playlist so
I'll just link that at the end of this
but they just want to let you know that
it's not gonna be a race to the finish
like he's not just gonna outrun the
villain and that'll be it but the
episode titles that we've learned about
so obviously you know episode 1 is
called flash reborn that's the one that
got the flash production office people
in super big trouble they posted a
picture and then like a day after that
everyone was talking about it and then
suddenly their Twitter account got
deleted so I was like oh they very
clearly we're not meant to reveal the
title of the first episode very clearly
a rift on flash rebirth whichever
version you're talking about you could
be talking about the Geoff Johns flash
rebirth from 2009 or the recent one that
they just did most of their Easter eggs
are probably going to come from the one
where Barry Allen came back because it's
Barry Allen coming back on the TV show
so episode 3 we learned is gonna be
titled luck be a lady
so obviously everybody probably
remembers that song but that's
episode where hazard from the comics
debuts she's the one that looks like
this she has crazy luck skills so
obviously you can imagine she goes to a
casino and tries to win a bunch of money
the flash has to stop her but then
Episode five we learned a whole bunch of
stuff about so I did a separate video
about that but it's called a girls night
out it sort of iris West doing bachelor
party stuff with an arrow crossover
Katee Sackhoff is guest starring as
blacksmith from the comics in supposedly
she's going to be running a big
underground fight ring that the flash
Barry Allen is going to have to fight in
so maybe Wally West will get involved in
that too but they kind of did a version
of that on Supergirl where she had to
fight in the ring for a brief period but
underground alien fight ring so the
flash is doing their version of that so
that kind of answers the question of how
they can do a girls night out style
episode but the flash is still a big
part of it but that aside most of the
footage from the comic book teaser that
they dropped even though it's really
cool is mostly footage from last season
I actually wish they would do more comic
book promos for these seasons but I
think their marketing budgets been
reduced quite a bit here's the promo for
that ratio which is going to take place
on earth X like the planet full of Nazis
so we'll get to see versions of our
characters that are either Nazis
themselves and villains or fighting the
Nazis or introducing a whole new earth
earth X we've got an entire planet
that's been taken over by Nazis with a
whole new group of superheroes and a lot
of super villains the androids pray give
it to me
not a chance so if it wasn't clear
Stephen Amell Grant Gustin all the
arrowverse actors will be crossing over
to that and they'll probably aired on CW
seed I'm not planning on doing any big
videos for it but I think the idea is is
that the Ray character will eventually
come on so the live-action shows the
same way that vixen did but I do love
the red Sun twist on Supergirl
only instead of being part of the Soviet
Union she's a Nazi but let me know in
the comments what are you guys pumped up
about there'll be some more promos like
this in the next couple weeks once we
get within about four weeks they'll
really start dropping footage but
congratulations to the latest flash ring
giveaway winner Zebby Clark please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details leave all your requests for
flash arrowverse bonus videos in the
comments below there's some more arrow
stuff that I might do a video for soon
they did say that the villains on arrow
would be a team-up so we already know
about Richard dragon we know about black
siren and then we know about Michael
Emerson playing a character but
everybody seems to think like they have
the wrong idea so we'll just see who he
winds up playing but while you wait for
everything you can click here for all my
blasts season 4 videos and you can click
here for brand-new Rick and Morty thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight